Hi, class. Dr. Jim here. In this lecture we're going to look at animal digestion. So we're
going to take the time and look at the nutrients that we need, how animals support themselves,
and then again, essentially how they get through the process of digestion. So we're going to
look at not only the human digestive system, but we're also going to look at other vertebrate
animals and see how they digest their food to get the important nutrients that they need.
Now again, what separates animals out from plants and other organisms like fungi is animals
are heterotrophs. We need to have to eat. So again, we have developed adaptations for
us to eat. And that was, again, we looked at that during chapter 27 when we looked at
the predation and again, the production of jaws and the teeth and all that good stuff.
So we'll look at that today in some of the specific adaptations that we came with. And
then the other thing is, is that we do internal digestion. So what separates animals out from
fungi is that they tend to digest externally and then absorb everything through their cell
walls. Whereas animals, they do everything internally. And so you're going to see that
with the sponges all the way up to humans, we all have internal digestion. And so sponges,
they have their pores again, and they do filter feeding. And then you start to see the
development of these gastrovascular cavities and then digested systems as they go on. Here's
just a cute little picture of different things of animals eating and that stuff. And again,
we see that most animals are either one of three types. They're either carnivores, which
mean they just eat meat. They're herbivores, meaning they eat plants, or they eat both,
which is an omnivore. And so again, a lot of that has to do. And you can look at the
teeth that these animals have. And you can see what they'll eat in that stuff. But again,
it's all about getting nutrients and what nutrients are important. So we'll take a look
at that as we go on today. So first thing we're going to ask is, why do animals have
to eat? Very simple question. Again, we're going to look at that. And again, getting
the nutrients that they need in order to survive. The second thing we're going to look at are
what are the steps of digestion. So we're going to take our, take our time going through
what digestion is. And again, look at the aspects and the organs that are involved with that.
And that's kind of the third topic as well. Then we'll look at the organs needed for digestion.
Where does chemical digestion take place? And look at what is the roles of each of the organs?
What are they supposed to do? And why do we have them? And then finally, look at the adaptations
that are correlated with various animal diets. And so we'll take a look at the differences
between herbivores and carnivores. And what does that effect have on their digestive system
in that and some of these other organisms that are out there? Okay. So chapter 33, we're
looking at digestion today. So we're going to be talking about the stomach, the intestines,
and looking at all those wonderful aspects that go on. So let's take the journey together
and let's go through and see what we can learn about the digestive system. And again, the need
to feed. So food is taken in and taken apart and taken up by the process. And the process
is known as animal nutrition. And in general, it falls into three categories. And I just
mentioned this before. Herbivores mainly eat plants, carnivores eat other animals and omnivores
eat both plants and animals. And again, most animals are also opportunistic feeders, meaning
they're going to look for whatever source of food they can find and they're going to
eat it. So again, that plays a role with the predator prey and then their herbivores of
well. And again, has had major effects on evolution as we've seen in other chapters.
Now the animal diet must supply energy, organic molecules, and essential nutrients. And so
again, chemical energy, which is converted to ATP and power cells. So you need carbohydrates
to do that. You need the organic building blocks, such as organic carbon, organic nitrogen to
synthesize a variety of organic molecules, the proteins, the proteins, carbohydrates
and glyco acids and lipids. And again, then we have the essential nutrients that are required
by cells and must be obtained by dietary sources. And so again, this is just the example of what
we think of fruits and grains and vegetables and protein. And again, having a variety is
always good. And so that's one of the things that we always have to think about is making
sure we get the right nutrients at the time. Now, essential nutrients must be obtained
from the animal's diet. And again, these are four classes that we need. And again, essential
amino acids to help build proteins, essential fatty acids, which are helped to maintain
again, membranes as well as neural transmitter, neural systems, hormones or lipids, a lot
of times, and some of these other guys that we need. And then vitamins and minerals that
are very important as well. And if we don't get these things, then they always suggest
getting taking vitamin supplements and that stuff because they're important for the body
as well. And you can kind of see in a list of some of the things that are necessary for
our body. So again, a little linoletic acid, prostaglandins are important, the fossil lipids,
again, the essential amino acids, which are listed here, mineral cofactor or the iron,
and then the vitamin B3 as a coenzyme to work on enzymes and that stuff. And so you can
kind of see different rules for these bodies. Now, some of the essential fatty acids and
amino acids, again, animals require 20 amino acids. So you can synthesize half the molecules
in their diet, the remaining amino acids are the essential amino acids and it must be maintained
from food. So we can make about half, but we have to get the essential ones. And these
are the essential ones on here. So histidine, isoleucine, leucine, lysine, methionine, phenylalanine,
thuroine, tryptophan and valine. And so again, these are the essential. There's some conditionally
not essential. Sometimes they're needed more and then these guys are really not essential
amino acids in that. And again, looking at the different types that are there. So these
we not necessarily have to get from our diet. And so that's, that's the idea. Now, fatty,
fatty acids, again, we need it for cellular components, such as fossil lipids, signaling
molecules, they talk about hormones and storage fats, again, for energy storage and that there
are essential fatty acids. And again, we can't synthesize them, but they can be synthesized
by plants. And again, we obtain these from these essential fatty acids by our diets.
And this includes things like omega sixes. So you can see where these things come from.
So this kind of gives you an idea and that where we get them, we also have the omega
threes. And again, a lot of people are lacking in the omega threes. So they take fish oil
or some of these other things that again, are very important. So again, we get a lot
of these from our diet. These not so much unless you eat a lot of fish or seeds and
that stuff. So again, that's why a lot of us are now taking supplements because we're
lacking these omega threes. And so a lot of times we get too many of these and not enough
of these. And so that's the, that's the thing that we need there. Now vitamins that are
essential. Again, these are the small required in small amounts, but they're essential again
for enzymes and other functions in there. You can see a list of some of the vitamins
that we need. A lot of times the B complexes and that vitamin D, vitamin E, vitamin K,
folic acid, vitamin A and all these other things. And so you can see some of the different
essential vitamins that we need and where we get them from. And again, natural source
versus other sources. So yeah, taking a look at that. And then the minerals again, these
are inorganic nutrients and again, required in small amounts. And again, getting these
things from our diet and including things like manganese, calcium, sodium, copper, again
fluorine, it's cesium, iron, zinc, all these different things. Again, a lot of these are
co-factors and enzymes as well as signaling molecules in ourselves or transporters in
that. So we need those as well. Now again, dietary deficiencies, if we don't get these
things and we become malnourished. And again, this is a long term absence from the diet
of one or more of these essential nutrients. And again, we've seen the sad stories and
that stuff, especially where you have a lot of famine and drought and other things. And
again, a lot of people in India as well as in Africa, where we see a lot of malnourishment.
And again, it says that again, every third individual is malnourished in the world today.
And so that's kind of sad that we live in a world as complex and cosmopolitan as we
have it. And we still see hunger as a major issue. And even in the United States, we see
that as an issue and that stuff, which is a sad, sad state affair, because the United
States is a very productive country, very rich country in history and also in monetary wealth
as well. And we still have children going to bed hungry every night and that stuff. And
that's kind of a sad statement to say for this country especially in that. So we look
at that and it can be a tough, tough situation. Now, deficiencies in nutrients can cause deformities,
disease and death. And again, sometimes animals will get salt, mineral and shells or stones
to prevent mineral deficiencies. And you can see here, this animal licking the rocks to
get in some nutrients. And so sometimes it's essential because they're not getting it in
their diet. And so they have to get it from other sources. And so a lot of times you'll
see animals licking rocks or ground or other things to get some of these minerals that
they may be deficient in. Now, a diet in sufficient amounts of one or more amino acids is the
most common type of malnutrition in among humans. Again, other diets often deficient in vitamin
A. And so one of the things we've seen is again synthesizing food with different vitamins
in them. And so one of the things is this golden rice, which now has vitamin A and beta
keratin in it. And so you see this thing called golden rice. And so this is one of the advantages
of bioengineering. You're putting nutrients in food that now is available and help the
male nourishment in different parts of the world. And so this is a good thing. And so
this is where GMOs can actually be very helpful in that. And again, GMOs get a bad name. But
again, this is one of the areas where it could be very beneficial in providing nutrients
for people that are male nourished in these situations. Now, under nourishment, again,
can arise when diets don't provide enough. And again, what happens in individual is they
used up the stored fats and carbohydrates. They start to break down their own proteins.
They lose muscle mass again, because of the breakdown, you suffer protein deficiency
of the brain. And eventually you can die and suffer irreversible damage. And again, this
doesn't have to be a third world country. We're talking about the United States to people
with eating disorders. And again, things like anorexia or some of these other eating disorders
where you definitely see this happen into people where they get very, you know, due to the psychological
effects and that stuff, they can basically waste away. And essentially, because they're
not getting the nutrients that they need and their body starts to eat themselves. And so
it's a sad situation when they're not able to maintain their normal and normal environment.
And again, they get this male nourishment because they're not getting enough food to
supplement their diet. And so that's, that's a, that's an interesting aspect as well when
you look at that. Now again, food processing can be divided into four stages. And so you
have ingestion, which is basically taking in the food and bringing it in digestion, which
is the chemical breakdown. And again, using the enzymatic hydrolysis. And then you have
absorption in the intestines, which absorb the nutrients into the rest of the body. And
then finally, you have elimination, which is getting rid of the excess or waste or undigested
material in these situations. And so again, this is why we eat. And so again, these are
the four stages, ingestion, digestion, absorption and elimination. And this is why we eat the
food we eat. Okay. Now, ingestion is the act of eating or feeding. And again, it's strategies
for extracting resources from through different widely among animals. You can see here, this
snake is eating this, essentially has constricted this, it looks like an antelope completely,
now it is swallowing it whole. And so again, these guys have onions, jaws, so they can
swallow their food. Most animals, again, predatory animals have his jaws, so they can't do that.
So they have to chew up their food and break it down first before they can ingest it. And
so depending on the type of animal, you see different mechanisms for ingestion. Now, digestion
is the process of breaking it down. And again, we have mechanical digestion, which is our
teeth. And again, some of the other things that help break these things down, the movement
of the food and breaking it down this way. And then you have the chemical digestion,
which is the enzymes which help break things down into smaller pieces as they pass through
and allow it to pass through the membranes. And so again, in chemical digestion, you have
hydrolysis that split bonds with addition of water and other things, the acid helps break
these things down and you look at these different things as we see it. So again, when you eat
that pizza, you can see all the different things that go on. And again, the ingestion
is the bringing the food in. Digestion is breaking it down. And then the next part is
going to be the absorption of taking these small molecules once you've broken it down
and then absorbing it. Okay, so absorption is the uptake of nutrients. And then the elimination
is getting rid of any undigested material out of that digestive system. And so again,
you can kind of see this ingestion is bringing it in. Digestion is breaking it down. Absorption
is absorbing the nutrients. And then finally, elimination is getting rid of those undigested
pieces. Now again, in most animals, processed food and specialized compartments. And again,
the compartments reduce the risk of animals digesting their own cells and tissues. And
so again, these systems are set up so that the digestion takes place in a closed system
and that they're protected for not having them leak out. Obviously, people can have issues
with that. But typically, we think of a closed system you have a tube inside of a tube. And
so our digestive system is kind of closed off from the rest of the rest of the body. And
again, eliminates these different things as we go along. And so again, keeps it in the
digestive system and not leach out into the rest of the environment. Okay, now we can
have intracellular digestion. And so again, when we think of single cells or in our bodies
where you have these food particles that come in, they can be digested internally by the
phagosome. The phagosome is basically brought in by the phagocytosis. You attach to the
lysosome. The lysosome contains the enzymes and then you break these things down. And then
the molecules are either brought in and absorbed by the cell or released through exocytosis.
So again, that's internal cells. And we see this during the process of absorption. And
once the material is broken down, and the individual cells are feeding on the little
morsels. Now, extracellular digestion is essentially where it breaks out down outside the cells.
And so again, there's compartments that are continuous with the outside of the animal's
body. And so again, even in the simple animals like the nideria, what you have is this gastrovascular
cavity, which essentially eats food, brings it in and releases enzymes to break this down.
And so again, in this situation with the gastrovascular cavity, you have internal digestion.
These get broken down and then the cells absorb the minerals once they're broken down. And
then anything that doesn't go gets excreted back out through the mouth. And so again,
whether you're a big animal like us or a small animal like the hydra, you do internal digestion
inside a tube or a vessel inside the body that releases enzymes. And then finally, it's
rid of the waste when it's been properly digested.
Now, more complex animals have a complete digestive tract or an elementary canal. And
again, with a mouth and anus. And so again, the mouth is responsible for bringing in food
and the anus is responsible for the elimination of the waste products. And again, most animals
have a complete digestive system. Again, it's really only the very simple animals like the
couple that I can think of that are very simple are the nigerians. So again, the jellyfish
or the hydra. And then the worms, the flat worms like the plenary typically have only
a incomplete digestive system. Most animals above that all have a complete digestive system.
So they have a way of to bring in the food and then a way to release the food animals.
We saw this when we did the view or the scan of the different animals, but we'll look again
more closely at digestion one, especially in the in the pigs when we do the dissection
of the pigs. And we'll look at that as well as the frogs as well and look at that and
see those different things. Okay, very similar. Okay. And again, it's the systems are the
same way. It's a big one too. It just depends on the type of organs that you have. And again,
these are some of the different things that you see. So sometimes you see crops and gizzards
other times you see stomachs in that. And again, the roles of these things all depend
on what they're supposed to do. And so again, we'll look at these as we go along throughout.
Okay. Now, in the mammalian digestive system contains the elementary canal and the accessory
glands that's increased the digestive juices. Again, it's one long tube all the way through.
And again, the accessory glands and the salivary glands, the pancreas, the liver and the gall
bladder all contribute digestive enzymes that help break down the food. So they are part
of the chemical digestion. And we'll talk about where and what happens during each part of
the digestive system here in a little while. Okay. Now the first stage of digestion is
mechanical and takes place in the oral cavity. And again, the chemical would be the grinding
of the teeth, tearing it up. And then the chemical digestion would be from the salivary
glands. And so you release saliva in the oral cavity to help again slide that down through
the esophagus as well as to start breaking down certain chemicals that are in the food.
And so again, one of the things that we have is amylase to help break down starches and
glucose polymers. Again, other things that we have is mucus and other things, water
salts and glycoproteins as well as some other lysosymes in that that help break down some
proteins and other things in the saliva itself. So you start to see some chemical digestion
as well. And we'll look at specifically what gets broken down here in a little while when
we look at chemical digestion. Now in the upper digestion, again, the tongue shapes the food
into a bolus. And so that bolus then works its way down into the esophagus. And again,
one of the things that we have is the epiglottis and that epiglottis helps close off so that
we don't swallow food into our respiratory system. And again, that's an important part
that's kind of the revolving door. Typically, it's closed when we're eating and then it
opens back up when we're breathing. And so again, sometimes you get water food and that's
when we get when we start to choke. And so it goes down the wrong, wrong hole, I guess
in that case, if you want to call it that a wrong tube, and then you may have the response
like a coughing response or you may need help like the heimlich response. And so you get
the food out of there. And so but hopefully it works its way down through the esophagus
and towards the stomach. And you can see some of the different ways that we use this. So
the teeth, again, help cut and grind the food. The tongue helps move the food down as well
as the different salivary glands that help again provide chemical digestion to break
down the food as it goes along. Now, swelling must be closely carefully choreographed to
avoid choking. And again, the epiglottis does protect that. And again, you want to make
sure that it's closed before you swallow and all that stuff. And so a lot of times choking
happens when we don't chew something fully and it gets kind of lodged in that area. And
so that's one of the issues that that people have. And again, then the esophagus conducts
food down from the pharynx down to the stomach using rhythmic cycles of contraction. We'll
talk about about that. That's called pterostalis. And again, causes the squeezing sensation to
work its way down to the stomach. And again, the form of the esophagus fits this function
in the various among species. And again, around to work the food down to the stomach. Now,
like I said, pterostalis is the rhythmic contractions of the muscles. And so the smooth muscles
that line this help constrict and contract and that contraction allows for the food to
work its way down to the stomach. And so we have these waves that essentially help push
it down. Now, also, we have these valves at the end of both the esophagus and on the
other end of the stomach. And at the other end of the digestive system that help regulate
the movement material between the compartments. And so we'll see this a couple of times. The
first sphincter we're going to see is the gastric, again, the gastric sphincter, or
I think it's called the esophageal sphincter in that case, where again, the food comes
down. And as the food comes down, it allows for the sphincter to relax and allows for
the food to enter in. Now, some people have issues where they get heartburn and they acid
from the stomach actually works their way through and can actually damage the esophagus
and the sphincter itself if they have chronic heartburn and that. And so people can develop
that as well. Now, once we get to the stomach, you have the digestive or gastric juices,
which basically convert the meal of the mixture into the digestive juice called kind. And so
it goes from a bolus to the alachain. You can see we have these pits inside of her stomach
that release the acid. And then the acid is from these pareto cells, which take chlorine
and the protons and convert it into hydrochloric acid. And the pepcidogen is then converted
to pepsin, which becomes the active enzyme that helps break down protein. And so the
HDL helps convert pepsinogen to pepsin. And then you have this reaction to help digest
the food in the stomach. And so this is how chemical digestion takes place inside the
stomach. And this just shows you the glands and that. And again, the mucus cells that
help coat the stomach to protect it so you don't get all serves in that from the acid
that's produced. Now again, the gastric juice has a low pH about two, which kills the bacteria
and helps the nature of proteins. And again, it's made up of hydrochloric acid and pepsin,
which helps break down proteins. And then it's a protease, meaning that it breaks down proteins
and it cleaves proteins into peptides. And so that's typically the chemical digestion
that's happening in the stomach is the pepsin breaking down the proteins in this case.
Now the mucus in the stomach protects it from the gastric juice. And then cell division
keeps adding new epithelial layers every three days to replace any cells damaged by
digestive juices. And so again, it's that chronic wearing away that can lead to ulcers. And so
you can see here's a normal stomach lining where you have this nice mucus layer as well
as cells replacing, whereas you get damaged where you get these areas where are the ulcer
forms. Now most people, and this is my microbiologist coming at you, get ulcers because they have
a bacterial infection. And so it's not actually due to, you know, worrying a lot or having
stress or other things. What really happens most of the time is you get this bacterial
infection called helochobacter pylori, which sits in the stomach wall. It actually raises
the pH so they can survive in there. And then it causes this wearing away of the lining.
The cells can't repair itself as fast. And so you get the cell damage as well as the mucus
goes away. And so you see this damage occurring. And so that's the big issue when you talk
about ulcers and that a lot of times is due to a bacterial infection and not just due
to stress or worry with that. And so I think they said it estimate about 90% of the ulcers
that are actually caused by bacterial infection rather than, you know, some of these other
things that we think about stress or worry or something else that goes on in these situations.
Now coordinated constriction, relaxation, and stomach muscle turn the stomach contents.
So it's kind of like this big bag that helps stir the stuff up. And then the sphincters
prevent the kind from entering the esophagus or coming into the small intestine. So again,
you have this cardio esophageal sphincter up at the top, which keeps it from going back
through the esophagus. And then you have the pyloric sphincter or the valve that keeps
it from going into the intestines until it's ready. And so again, you get this digestion
and typically it takes anywhere from two to six hours to go from the stomach into the
intestine for the food to move in. And so it's quite a while in the stomach, just digesting,
and turning, and processing the chemical digestion, breaking down the proteins and eventually
going into the stomach. So you'd assume that probably things that are higher protein are
going to take longer to digest. And so that's one of the reasons why if you want to lose
weight, they say eat a lot of protein, because it takes longer to digest. And so it's one
of those things that you have to sit there and break it down longer. So you feel fuller,
and it takes you a longer to break these things down. Same thing with fiber. That's the other
thing because you can't digest it and it sits in your system and makes you feel full.
Okay, now once the food, the bolus, and the kind who's into the small intestine, it enters
into what we call the duodenum. And we've looked at that in chapter 32, how the cells
regulate the pH. And so when it enters in here, travels through the pyloric sphincter
and enters into the duodenum, what you see is that the pH goes up to about a seven.
Now what happens here is that digestion still occurs in the small intestine, but you now
start to see absorption. And so again, in the small intestine, you see all these little
billi that allow for the, again, pre surface area so you can do more digestion and absorption
in these places. And like I said, person is in the duodenum. And again, the kind mixes
with digestive juices from the pancreas, liver, gallbladder, intestinal wall to further break
things down. And so again, we get further breakdown in the smaller units and we start
to see absorption and that and then we move into the large intestine here in a minute.
Now, the roles of the pancreas, we look at the pancreas. And again, one of the things
that it produces is the chymal trypsin, which is activated by the duodenum. One, it helps
neutralize the acidic chym in there. We talked about that, the regulation of again, the secretenin,
secretenin gets released by the duodenum, which triggers the pancreas, just add bicarbonate
in and again, causing the things to raise the pH up. So that's one of the things that
it does. The other thing that it does is it releases this trypsin in that, which helps
also breakdown proteins as we go along. Now, in the small intestine, bile adds indigestion
and absorption of fats. And so again, if you have a problem with your gallbladder or you're
missing your gallbladder, one of the things that Dr. tells you is watch fatty foods because
you're not as likely to eat or not as likely to digest fats as well because you're missing
a lot of your bile. And that in that bile helps breakdown the fatty tissue. And so when
you're losing your gallbladder because it gets blocked by a gallstone or it gets diseased
or damaged, you have this removed. You still can make bile from your liver. You just don't
have a lot of it stored. And so again, it's more about moderation. And so you still can
eat fatty foods, but you have to be very careful because you just don't produce it or you don't
have as much bile. And so that's the problem. Bile is also the reason why your poop turns
out brown because it adds that color, it adds the there. And so when you see damage to the
liver, a lot of times you get jaundice in that and that's the bilirubin that accumulates.
Well, that's the color in the bile and that the greenish color and that and that gives
you the color that you see in your poop. So that's why you see that it also destroys non-functional
red blood cells as well. So runs that are dying. Now, let's take a look at the chemical
digestion. So we talked about this first. So really in the oral cavity, the one that
takes place there is in the saliva. So you have this amylase that helps break down the
polysaccharide. So things like starch and glycogen, sucrose and lactose and maltose into smaller
polysaccharide. So that's the first thing you see. So primarily in the mouth, the chemical
digestion is going to be on the sugars in that. Okay. Then when you move to the stomach, the
stomach will also continue on with the carbohydrate digestion and has again enzymes that breaks
these things down as well as the protein digestion with the pepsin. And so again, that's what
takes place with the acid and that helps break down the protein. So again, in the stomach,
so now you've got carbohydrate and protein digestion. And then finally, when you move
into the small intestine, you start to see the rest of the nutrients being broken down.
So again, you see carbohydrate digestion with again, pancreatic amylases, you see more protein
digestion with trypsin and chymotrypsin. And then you now start to see nucleic acid digestion
through the nucleases that are found in the pancreas and then the pancreatic lipase along
with bile with the fat digestion. And we're going to look at all these. So really, the
main place of digestion and chemical digestion takes place in the intestines, but the stomach
and the mouth start the carbohydrates and the protein digestion first. And then the rest
of these things get digested in the small intestine. Okay. And then the other other things from
other chemicals as well for carbohydrates. Again, you see digestion that protein digestion
and then nucleic acid as well. So we've talked about all these different things as well.
Now, absorption starts to take place in the small intestine as well. And again, that's
why you have the villi and the micro villi, which again, increases the surface area so
you can digest more. And so the enormous micro villi or surface area creates broader brush
broader of increased rate of nutrient absorption. And again, without it, we wouldn't be able
to absorb as well. And so that villi really increases surface area so you can absorb that
much more food. And so again, makes it much more efficient in a much more efficient system.
Otherwise, we'd group in a lot more if we didn't absorb quite as much in that. So it
does help with that the absorption. You can see here, again, the blood vessels are attached
to the intestine. They absorb the nutrients and that stuff. We see the absorption with
the villi. You increase the surface area by having more of these as opposed to just a
flat surface. You have so many more cells to absorb these cells absorb and then pass the
nutrients into the blood. And so those things get into the blood and do those different
things and then absorb the food or the nutrients, I'm sorry, in these cases. Now, one of the
important veins in this case is the hepatic portal vein, which carries nutrients blood
from the capillaries to the villi to the liver and then to the heart. And again, the liver
regulates nutrient distribution, intercoverse many organic molecules and detoxifies many
organic molecules. So really, the liver is there for an important reason, and that's
to detoxify anything that we bring in. It also controls where the nutrients are going
to go in the body. And so it's kind of the control center saying, okay, we got all these
nutrients, where do we need them the most? And it's kind of like the distribution center
of the shipping center and says, okay, we need nutrients here, we need nutrients here
and the liver can do that. It also detoxifies things. So if there's toxins that you get
in the food, or if you're naughty and drink alcohol, the liver does detoxify those things
so that it becomes less of an issue in your body and detoxifies those types of things.
So having a good functional liver is always important. So you can see people that have
bouts of alcoholism and that stuff where they've destroyed their liver over a long period
of time. Because their liver doesn't work as well, you get things like cirrhosis, sometimes
you get liver cancer and other liver damage that can have a major effect on how well someone
can detoxify the nutrients in their body. And so when you get liver damage, you start
to see a lot of other things happen and so it's bad news all the way around. So again,
you want to keep your liver happy because it's keeping you safe. And so that's an important
thing when we think about that. Now with the fats, again, epithelial cells absorb the
fatty acids and then monoglyglycerides and recombine them to triglycerides. And that's
how they're moved around in the blood. And again, they're transported into the lacteal
in lymphatic vessels of the villi and the lymphatic vessels develop the cycle of micron containing
lymph in large veins that return the blood to the heart. And so that's how the fats get
into the blood is actually through the lymphatic system and they promote it. So here you can
see here's a fat globule and the bile salts that are produced by again liver that's stored
in the gallbladder help break down the fat droplet and they break it down into the fatty
acids and the monoglycerides. Those things then get absorbed by the epithelial cells
and they're formed into triglycerides, which then end up in the lymphatic system, not in
the blood system, but in the lymphatic system, which is then carried away by the lymph system,
which then circulates back to the heart. And so your lymph system is actually very important
for moving fats around in your body. So the fats do end up in your blood eventually,
but again, most of the fats that are digested end up in the lymphatic system first and then
are added into the essentially into circulation through the veins near or around the heart
because that's where the main lymphatic duct enters into the circulatory system. So again,
we'll talk more about the lymphatic system in chapter 35. Okay, now once the food enters
into the large intestine, so the colon of the large intestines connected, you have the
secum that adds in the fermentation of plant material. And again, where the large and small
intestines meet. Now in certain animals that are herbivores, they're going to have a much
larger secum and that appendix actually does a lot more. And so what we've seen is that
the appendix does contain some certain bacteria and other cells that help with the immunology.
And so otherwise, we're not really sure what the appendix does other than causing issues
in people and they have appendicitis. And so they get inflammation of that and it can
cause problems because if it ruptures, you now get the leakiness of whatever was in the
appendix into the surrounding tissues and that can cause a severe bacterial infection
and that can be very bad for people. So that's why you have to get that taken care of if
you do feel that inflammation or pain associated with appendicitis. So again, the main part
of the large intestine though, is to take the food and absorb the water that comes out
of it. And so that's going to be the key. And again, you have lots of wonderful little
bacteria in there that help aid in the digestion in that sense situation. And sure enough, here
we talk about this. And so one of the major functions is to recover the water that has
entered into the alimentary canal. And again, the colon houses the bacteria that live on
unabsorbed organic material and produce some vitamins for us. And again, the feces, which
makes it through the large intestine, include undigested material, bacteria, and again becomes
more solid as it goes along because you're absorbing the water. Now, if you have a situation
where you have diarrhea or something, what's happening is your body is secreting water.
And so a lot of times you can get bacterial infections or other types of infections that
cause the intestines to secrete water. And that's why you get diarrhea. So normally,
normally your body will reabsorb most of the water. And so it should be more of a solid
kind of feces as opposed to a very liquidy. If it's coming out liquidy, you may have some
problems with reabsorption of that. And again, may have some intestinal issues with inflammation
or other things that are going on in your system. And I like this, the good and bad flora, again,
E. coli is good, the bifidobacteria and then the lactobacilli are all good bacteria. And
these are all part of the probiotics. Not only do they provide benefits, but the other thing
that they do is when they grow in there, they're keeping the pathogens away. They're keeping
the bad guys away, like campylobacter, endorococcus vicalis, which can be bad. And then
the cluster dium difficile. These guys are mostly pathogens and they cause pretty much
bad infections in your intestines. And so they cause a lot of times, watery diorias,
bloody diorias, and chronic diorias where they start eating away at the intestines so
they can be very bad news over a series of time. And so again, if you want to know more
about that, take microbiology and you'll definitely talk about some of the different
infections that go on in the intestines themselves.
Now the elimination part, so now if you've absorbed everything and removed the water,
you have now the elimination. And again, it makes it to the rectum, which is kind of
the storing site of the feces until it's ready to be eliminated. And again, there are two
sphincters in those who have the external anal sphincter and the internal anal sphincter,
which control the elimination of the feces. And so again, those are muscles that are very
tight. And again, relax when you're eliminating the feces at this part. And again, typically
we have control over that. Sometimes we don't, depending on how much is being stored in
the rectal area. And sometimes we get blocked up because we don't have enough fiber or water
in the system. And so it gets backed up. And that's what is called constipation, where
you can't eliminate during that time.
Okay, now if we look at this, the evolutionary adaptations of vertebrate digestive systems
correlate with their diet. And so digestive systems are again, variations of the common
plant. So whenever we look at the common plant, it's a long tube that essentially helps again
with the four states of digestion. So you have ingestion, you have digestion, you have
the absorption and then elimination. And depending on what you're eating and what you're doing,
will determine what type of system you have. So you can see in the insectivore, again, typically
in the insectivore, which eats insects. Again, there are a long short intestine, again, a
short intestine in this case, and really no large intestine. It gets a little bit larger
in that in the elimination. But again, there's no cecum because they're not eating any, they're
not eating any plants. And so again, they don't really need that digestion. So you don't see
that in this case. Now in a non ruminant herbivore, you see a simple stomach, which then passes
into a very long intestine, you can see the cecum, which contains a lot of enzymes that
help break down plant material in that. And so you see a large one of those, and again,
a large intestine to absorb the water. In a ruminant herbivore, which has again, a rumin
and a stomach, which holds a lot of these things. So a lot of digestion takes place here.
You can see you have a very large small intestine in this case, again, long, and then a large
cecum, which helps digest any other further undigested plant material, and then a long,
large intestine to help remove the water in any of their absorption that needs to be done.
And then a carnivore, which you see is a very short intestine in column and a very small
cecum because again, you're primarily eating animals and not plants. And so if you don't
have plants in your diet, you're going to have a small cecum. Now humans kind of in between
because we're omnivores. Again, we eat plants, but a lot of the plant stuff we don't actually
digest, we pass it through. And so again, in our diet, plants are good because we get
oils and minerals and that stuff from plants. But one of the things that's also good is
we get fiber and we don't digest that fiber and it helps clean us out. And so that's why
fiber is always good because one, it makes us full. And so we don't want to eat more.
And two, it helps clean out the system because we don't digest it. And so it passes through
and so it's a good, good source to clean out. So if you want to clean your system out and
do one of those cleanses, you eat a lot of fiber in this case. You eat a lot of vegetables
and that stuff, a lot of plants help clean you out. Now another thing that we see with
the adaptations is the type of teeth. And so again, the type of teeth are going to revolve
around what do you eat. And so in a carnivore, you're going to have teeth that are specialized
for tearing and chewing. So you're going to see well-developed canines, you're going
to see incisors and then you're going to see molars to kind of grind in that stuff. And
so that's what you see here. So the carnivore is going to be primarily for ripping and tearing.
And so you're going to see well-developed teeth, especially in the front. And then the back
teeth are going to be lesser-developed. In a herbivore, you're not going to see really
a whole lot of incisors and canines because you don't need to do a lot of rippin and tearing
a muscle. You're going to see a lot of grinding though. So you're going to see a lot of cream
molars and molars in the back that help grind and break down the plant material. And then
in an omnivore, you have both. And so in humans, a great example, we have incisors and canines
that are developed to help rip and tear meat and other things that we eat. And then we
have the molars back here that help grind any plant material as well as meat and other
foods that we eat. And so it's one of those things that we see. Now some animals even
have other types of mechanisms that help them eat. And again, for example, the teeth
of a poisonous steaks have fangs that can inject venom. And so that can paralyze the
host or not the host, but it paralyze the prey so that they can help eat the thing and catch
it and eat it and do those things. And so that's an important adaptation that you see.
Not all animals obviously have fangs or a venom to inject and then paralyze their prey
in these cases. Now again, some other adaptations we talked about this with the type of food
you eat. So again, the adaptation is an apparent length of the digestive system in different
vertebrates. Many carnivores have a large expandable stomachs, again, for the amount
of meat that they use. And then herbivores and omnivores generally have longer elementary
canals and carnivores, because again, they need longer time to digest the vegetation.
So if you eat plants, you need more time to digest it. And so that's what you're going
to see. And you're going to see larger cecums. Again, carnivores, less cecum because they
don't need the bacteria in the vitamins and minerals that are not vitamin enzymes to
break down plant material. These are primarily eating meat. Whereas those that eat plants
like herbivores and omnivores are going to have cecums to help digest the plant material
that they eat. And again, humans are kind of in between because we more meat than plants,
even if we're omnivores and that stuff, but we don't have well developed cecums in the
sense that, again, you look at our appendix and that stuff, where you see here, ours is
pretty short. And again, containing some enzymes that help digest that plant material. And again,
ours is pretty small, kind of more like a carnivore than what you would see in a complete
herbivore in this case. Now, again, a lot of times, herbivores will have fermentation
chambers in their elementary canals where microorganisms can digest the cellulose. And
so again, that's one of the things that we see. And so herbivores are going to have multiple
chambers, especially in basically rumin's that are essentially helping digest. And so
they have bacteria in there that help break down the cellulose. Again, in humans, we're
omnivores. And so we don't really break that stuff down. And so that, again, helps
us feel full and clean us out in those types of things. Now other bacteria can be very
beneficial. Again, we have E. coli and other things that help provide vitamins and help
break things back down. But obviously, we can get bacterial infections and those can
be a big issue in that. And so again, one of the things that we see is that sometimes
when we get pathogens, they can eliminate other species of bacteria from the stomach.
And again, we see that these are the ones that cause the infection. And you can see
that eliminates the bacteria, other bacteria that are normally in the stomach when you
have this type of infection. And so that's the problem, too, is that people that have
these infections with helochobacter lose a lot of the other ones. Same with C diff. And
so one of the big problems with clustering difficil is that people have been in antibiotics
for a very long time. And so it eliminates their normal microflora. So it allows for these
guys to grow because the normal microflora is gone to the antibiotics. And then what you
see is these guys take over and then they get this chronic diarrhea that doesn't go away.
So one of the ways to treat a patient that has C diff is by eliminating the antibiotics,
which seems counterintuitive. But what happens is then you restore some of the native micro
biological environment. The other way, and a lot of people find this out and they go,
wow, this is interesting as they do what is called fecal transplants. And what they do
is they take fecal material from other healthy people, and they transplant it into people
that don't have very good systems. And so people that have eliminated a lot of their
normal bacteria to reestablish that bacterial population. It sounds weird, but it actually
works really well. And so again, you may see this more and more common where people are
going in. And again, typically how they do this is they make either pills or they inject
it in or some way to get the fecal material in there. So it sounds gross, but it actually
works really well. And so again, it's an interesting concept, but it's done wonders for those that
have suffered chronically from clustered into fissile and some other digestive disease that
are out there because reestablish them, the microbiome really helps in these situations.
Now other mutualistic adaptations, and again, in herbivores, you have these
rumin's which store a lot of these bacteria. They can help digest cellulose in that and break
these down into simple sugars. And again, the rumin's help break these things down. So things
like cut shooting animals and include deer, sheep, and cattle have these large rumin's that are
basically these large filled bags full of bacteria that help break down the cellulose. And so that's
why they're in herbivores. And they are able to break down the stuff so well because they have
these bacteria in it. It's another thing that we see in termites. The termites have the bacteria
that help break down cellulose and so they can eat wood and break down the cellulose because
they have the bacteria in their digestive system that allow them to do that. And so we see that in
termites and ants, carpentry ants that break down the wood and then cause problems in our houses and
that stuff. So that's the other issue you see there. Okay, and again, feedback circuits regulate
digestion, energy allocation, and appetite. And again, animals then take a food and nutrients
are matched to the circumstance and need. We talk about that. And again, the regulation or
digestion is every step of the way. And so again, the enteric division of the nervous system helps
regulate the digestive process. And you can see integrins play a huge role in what regulates
digestion. And so you have positive feedback. And so when food comes in, you get gastrin,
which produces gastric juices from the pancreas and other places, you have other hormones that
secrete from again, bile from the gallbladder and that incicretin, which releases bicarbonate.
We talked about that last time in the CCK, which stimulates enzymes released from the
pancreas. And then you also see inhibition of certain things to stop the production
gastric juices once it's made its way through the intestine. So again, or into the intestine
out of the stomach. So now they can stop the chemical digestion in the stomach and producing
the acid that you have in that. So that's these are all different feedback mechanisms. You can see
some are positive and some are negative based on what is going on in the system.
Okay. And again, energy allocation. This is all about biorenerogenics. And again, nutritional
leads and the animals energy used per unit is called as metabolic rate. And so one of the
interesting things is that animals that have are warm blooded are going to have higher metabolic
rates because they use in metabolism to maintain the again, how much heat they produce. Again,
this can figure out the rate of heat loss, the amount of O2 consumed and the amount of CO2 produced.
And we call that the metabolic rate. Now, like I said, and I was mentioning, we're going to see
that here in a second, is that metabolic rate is very tied very closely and especially endotherms
because we can regulate it based on our body temperature. We need metabolism to keep us warm.
And so if we don't eat enough, we get cold. And so that's one of the issues that again, we need
our metabolism to keep going so we can keep our body temperature the same way. And so again,
you see this organic molecules going in, digestion absorption, breaking these things down. You do
lose some heat off. And again, all these because we're taking and changing energy from one form
to another, we do lose heat. And again, formation of ATP. And you can see all these different things,
waste and loss of energy and that stuff. But again, enough to do the processes that we need. And so
again, if we're deficient in any areas, we have problems in this internal environment. And that's
always an issue in ourselves. Now, the minimum metabolic rate is an animal, or again, maintaining
this minimal metabolic rate for cell functions. And this metabolic rate, or BMR, is a minimum rate
that non-growing endotherm at rest on an empty stomach and is not experiencing stress. And so
that would be the metabolic rate. What is your cells doing when you have an empty stomach? You're
just kind of dormant, not doing anything. You're old, so you're not growing at all. So your body's
not doing those types of things. You're after the age of maturity and an adult. And essentially,
you're just sitting there on the couch type of thing and not experiencing any stress. So couch
potato, that would be your BMR. But anytime you're doing those things, you are looking at it. And so
what we measure typically is when we fast. And so that's what we look at when we look at your
metabolic rate. You have to fast. So you're not eating anything, again, an adult, and you're not
stressed out. So those are the things that you can see that your BMR decreases as you get older.
And the reason for that is because you're still growing as an into an adult. And so your metabolic
rate is going to be much higher. And then as you age, it gets slower and slower and slower.
And that's one of the reasons why as you age, you start putting more pounds on because your
metabolic rate decreases because you're not doing metabolism as fast. And so a lot of the stuff gets
stored as opposed to breaking down. And so when you're 20, it's easy to eat a whole pizza by
yourself and not feel the effects. But when you get to 40 and 50, it's much harder to look at that
or, you know, to get rid of it. You basically look at the pizza and you put on five pounds. And that's
just because your metabolic rate slows down as you as you go. Now, again, in an ectotherm is also
caused the standard metabolic rate because again, they're fasting and that stuff. And an endotherm
and ectotherm is a little bit different in the sense because they're more responsive to the
external environment where these guys have to maintain internally. So when we look at endotherapy,
again, it's more energetically costly than ectotherm because we have to maintain our metabolic
basically our temperature. And so again, the colder it is, the more our metabolic rate goes up.
And then as the temperature increases, the more the rate goes down. And in ectotherm,
it's the opposite. The ectotherm really doesn't change until it really gets warm.
And so the metabolic rate drops as the external rate drops. And so that's the ectotherm. And again,
the as the external there goes down, we got to maintain our temperature so we burn more. And so
that's why the metabolic rate goes up as an endotherm. Ectothermic goes down because when they cool off,
they slow down. And so they don't need to do as much because that's how they are. And so that's
what you see. Ectotherm, again, you see the metabolic rate drops when the temperature drops.
Endotherms, it actually goes up as the temperature drops because you've got to maintain that body
temperature. And so that's the issue there. Okay. And so again, regulation of energy storage,
the liver and muscle cells are used first and the energy is stored as glycogen. When these are full,
excess energy is stored is fat. And so this is the issue that we suffer from. And so this is why,
as humans, we're seeing an increase in obesity because we're taking in more calories, more food,
and that stuff. And we're not using it as much. We're not being as active as we should. And so we
see, again, in kids, the the rate of obesity going up because they're eating very high sugary
snacks. And that sugar is not being burned off. So they're not running around and planning more,
they're playing video games and being sedentary. And so you see a decrease. And again, the decrease
in the metabolic rate, you're also seeing these things stored. And so that's the problem. And so
when the fewer calories are taken in and expended, the body expands the liver and glycogen,
micro glycogen, and then fat are then burned. And so again, it's all about calories in calories
out. But again, we know that there's other factors in that stuff. So it's easy to say, oh, yeah,
just stop eating. But we need the nutrients as well. And so one of the problems is, is our diet in
general, and that stuff. And you guys probably know by looking at that and seeing the problems
that we have, if we have lots of sugar in our diet and those things, those things get stored.
And that's why we see this increase in fat deposits and that stuff and why we're getting heavier and
heavier and heavier, because there's a lot of sugar and processing in our foods, and they're not
natural, let the body in our body normally knows how to deal with. And that's one of the issues as well.
Now with glucose comingostasis, again, insulin and glycogen or glycogen are together maintained
in glucose levels. Insulin rises after a carbohydrate rich meal, and glucose entering the liver through
the hepatic portal vein is used to synthesize glycogen. So it gets stored. When glucose concentration is
low, the hepatic portal vein, glucagon stimulates liver to break down glycogen with these glucose
into the blood. And so insulin and glucagon are basically the feedback loops. When you don't have,
when you have glucose coming into the system, insulin goes, so it brings more glucose into the
liver to be stored. When those levels go down, insulin goes down, and then glucagon or glucagon
comes up to then produce again and release glycogen so it gets burned. And so that's essentially what
happens in the body. So you can see here, again, feedback loops. And so when the glucose level rises,
such as after eating, you get an introduction of insulin that causes the transport of glucose into
the cells. And so then the blood level, glucose level falls back to the normal level. And then
what happens if it falls too much, like after fasting, what happens is you get this secretion
of glucagon, and then glucagon causes the breakdown of glycogen and glucose into the blood, and then
you can see what the levels are. So normally when we think about diabetes and that stuff, and we're
going to talk about that here in a second, we have a dysfunction in this system. And so this is why
you have to fast when they're measuring your blood glucose, because if you eat something,
it may cause the glucose levels to be too high, and then it will give you a false, a false high
number, you know, type of thing. So a false, a false positive in this case, I guess, if you want
to look at it that way, whereas if you do fasting, it's going to lower the levels to more of a
maintenance level. And again, you're going to see where your normal glucose levels are based on that.
Okay, now again, the last thing we're going to talk about is diabetes. And again, diabetes,
malitis is a disease caused by the deficiency of insulin, or a decrease in the response of
insulin in the target tissues. And so part of the problem is that glucose cannot or cells can
are unable to take up glucose to meet their metabolic needs. And so fat becomes the main
substrate of cellular respiration. And so again, what happens in type one is that it's actually an
immune response. And so what happens is that you have low insulin because the pancreas is
essentially destroying the cell or the immune system is destroying the pancreas in the production
of insulin. So you don't have enough insulin in your body to respond to the glucose levels.
And so you don't have unable to use the glucose to insulin. So what happens is that the body is
constantly using fat deposits to serve as the glucose source. And so that can be an issue because
again, it affects circulation and it affects a lot of other things that go on and it damages
tissues over time. Now type two is when the insulin is not being recognized by glucose anymore. And so
the receptor is damaged in that. And so insulin is not up taking glucose right. And this is typically
due to a dietary thing. And so again, getting too much sugar in the diet and the insulin is not
responding to the glucose levels anymore. And so that's the issue here. And so again, you have
high levels of glucose in the body. And instead of keeping it in a nice steady state, you have
these fluctuations that are going up and down either way too much glucose or crashing. And so
that can be an issue again in those situations. Now type one again is an autoimmune disorder.
Typically it's genetic in that and the immune system destroys the pancreatic beta cells. So again,
insulin is not being produced. And so the issue there is that because the glucose levels are not
responding to insulin, you can go from very high to low depending on what you're eating. And so
people can go into coma with a crash because they don't have enough glucose in their body.
Type two is characterized by the failure of the target spells through actually responding
normal insulin. And again, heredity is a factor in type two, as well as excess body weight and
lack of exercise. So typically it's associated with a BCD and other issues with food consumption
of that. And so we see that with the type two. Type one is more of an autoimmune. And again,
people are typically have genetic or hereditary effects with the type one in this case.
Now obviously, again, we've talked about the over, over nourishment in that causes obesity,
which results from excessive intake of food and stored as fat. And again, obesity contributes to
diabetes, cancer, breast, cancer of the colon and breast, heart attacks and strokes because you get
fat deposits in the vessels is that. And again, we have discovered several mechanisms that help
regulate body weight. I'm going to show you one of them here in just a minute. But one of the issues
is again, is consumption, again, over consumption, especially of high carbohydrates. And that is a
big problem because they get stored as fat. And so that's the issue. Now, one of the hormones that
actually triggers obesity is called grilling. And grilling is a hormone that is secreted by the
stomach and it triggers the feeling of hunger before meals. And so this is a stomach where I'm
stomach. This is when you get that sensation of, man, I'm so hungry, I could eat like this whole
pizza right now. I'm just so hungry. And that's that grilling that's really kind of triggering that
that sensation that you want to eat and get you ready to eat. Then the insulin and PYY hormones
are secreted by the small intestines after you need to suppress the appetite. And so that's
now slowing yourself down. So now that you're full, you want those things. And then there's
another hormone leptin, which is produced by fat tissue that suppresses appetite. And again,
depending on how many things you have there. One of the biggest issues, and again, I suffer from
this is eating too fast because it doesn't allow your body to send those signals fast enough
to respond to appetite. And so what we have to do, and again, this is a problem with society in
general, is we go too fast sometimes and we need to stop and enjoy our food. Because when we eat
on the run and we eat very fast, we're not allowing our bodies to catch up and regulate our appetite.
And so what happens is when we eat fast and we're just downing the food left and right,
we're not getting the typical response that we see with our hormone levels and our hormones
can't catch up. And so one of the things that they say is if you want to control your appetite
and you want to make sure that you're not eating so much is slow down. Take the number of bites
in chew and then slow down and enjoy the experience. And so you can eat what you want. But if you slow
down, your body is going to tell you, okay, I'm full, I don't need to eat anymore. But if you eat
really fast and you're just downing everything left and right, your body doesn't have time to
tell you you're full. And so you don't get the signal. And so you continue to eat until,
you know, and then finally you feel like, oh, and then now you've overeat. And now you have too many
of these over nourishment, essentially. And now that gets stored as fat. So one of the ways they
figured this out. And again, just using it is just by slowing down. So I guess that's another way to
look at it, slow down, slow your role so that you, you slow down in the digestion. And so look at that
and see how that goes. Now this is just a summary of how these things work. Again, we talked about
the four stages of of really physical digestion. Again, the mouth is the ingestion part you bring
it in, you chew it, you have secretions from the salivary glands that help break down the carbohydrates.
It works its way down the esophagus to the stomach where you get secretions from the gastric lands,
which not only do carbohydrates, but proteins. And then you get the digestion in the small intestine,
again, the secretion of different enzymes and that from the small intestine, the liver and the
pancreas, which helps break down really all four major macromolecules, carbohydrates,
proteins, lipids and nucleic acids. The lipids leave due to the vial in that. And again,
the breakdown into the triglycerides, which end up in the lymphatic system, which end up then into
the veins that go to the heart. And then again, the absorb food, the absorption part in the small
intestine and a large intestine take place and again absorb it and go into the vessels that go to
the liver. And then the liver can detoxify or tell where the nutrients need to go, what needs to go
where the central receiving kind of thing or central stripping and says, we're going to ship
this up to the rest of the body. And again, the large intestine is necessary for the absorption
of water. And that's primarily what you see there as well as the microorganisms that you have there
that help aid in digestion and help again provide certain vitamins and minerals that you might need.
And then finally, any food that isn't digested gets eliminated through elimination and that goes
through the rectum and anus. The rectum is kind of the holding center and then the anus when you're
ready to alleviate or expel the waste product. And so that's really looking at mammalian
digestion. It really doesn't change except for again, some of the adaptations depending on what
type of organs you know are again herbivores have sometimes these large bags called rumin's that have
bacteria that help break down the cellulose and help that go. They also have the secum part of
the large intestine that contain enzymes and bacteria that help break down again plant material.
carnivores tend not to have any rumin's they have a short pretty much short intestine just to absorb
and then again a short small intestine and large intestine and then no secum because again they're
not really digesting any plant material so it's not needed and then eliminated. And then omnivores
are kind of in the middle in that so again that's kind of giving you the summary of the mammalian
digestion. So we made it to the end and again we looked at animal diets that must supply
chemical energy, organic building blocks and essential nutrients and we talked about
the essential amino acids, the essential lipids that you need and then the vitamins and minerals
and those things and again mel nourishment is when you're lacking those things and the most common
thing that we're missing is vitamins and amino acids and so again that's where the the GMOs come
from and that stuff and so again we talked about that before. Again food processing involves the
four stages in digestion which is coming through the mouth digestion which is both the mechanical
and chemical digestion of breaking the food down, absorptions taking those food or particles and
bringing them in through the intestinal wall and that and supplying the nutrients to the rest of
the body and then elimination is getting rid of the waste products in those in those in those
situations. Again we talked about a lot of the different organs specialized for sequential stages
of food processing. We took you through the mammals in the mammalian stages and again looking at what
the stomach does small intestine, large intestine and then the accessory organs and what they do
for digestion and eating in both chemical digestion and mechanical digestion and then finally absorption
and again we looked at adaptations we talked about that the difference between herbivores
and carnivores not only in the digestive system but the type of teeth they have so again looking
at those things and then we also looked at the feedback circuits that regulate digestion and
again for energy minerals and that and then again slowing down doing those things but when things
get out of whack that can have a huge effect on the body and again too much of a good thing can
lead to storage and then weight gain and all those other things. Okay so with that we made it to the
end of the this lecture if you have any questions please feel free to ask you know send me an email
whatever you need to do to contact me and that stuff if you have any questions I'm glad you're
watching the videos hopefully you're getting some on it hopefully learning something new in that and
I will see you next time.
Thanks for watching.